[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com well the government shutdown
has ended and we're quickly learning
more and more about why donald trump has
sort of been all over the place on what
it would take to end the government
shutdown and it appears that it all
along had everything to do with john
kelly and steven miller and i told you
before that donald trump at one point
said hey i would do a clean dhaka bill
said it - dianne feinstein on national
TV then backed off of that then at
another point donald trump said oh i
would sign any bipartisan legislation
that lands on my desk to avoid a
shutdown but then he refused to sign a
piece of bipartisan legislation that
actually did land on his desk at another
point he said that his us-mexico wall
must be part of the daca approval but
then that went away and now there's a
great new report from The New York Times
that at least partially explains what's
going on it was all along Donald Trump's
elegant chief of staff John Kelly and by
the way the reason I say that is there's
this really weird interview from a
couple months back where Trump kept
referring to John Kelly as being elegant
and it was just so good and we never
figured out why but now I call him the
elegant John Kelly not surprising he is
an elegant guy oh yes I guess it's not
it's not inaccurate it's just weird that
that what Trump is focused on so the
elegant John Kelly and Trump's
outrageous policy advisor Stephen Miller
have been pushing Trump to just keep
going demanding extreme immigration
policy before relenting on the shutdown
of course that ultimately didn't happen
the shutdown has been ended even
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham has
pointed to Stephen Miller as just being
an obstacle to ending this entire thing
saying quote as long as Stephen Miller
is in charge of negotiate
immigration we are going nowhere he's
been an outlier for years it actually
might be that Trump is being exploited
here by his staff because it's been
clearer and clearer to me that Trump all
along did want to end the shutdown and
sort of was confused about why they
couldn't um Trump's confused about many
things but one of the things he was
confused about was why they couldn't end
or have avoided this shutdown but it's
his own team that was pushing him to
keep it going and this actually relates
to the topic of leaks
Michael Wolf's book fire and fury says
straight up that part of the reason for
the leaks that are just endless coming
out of the Trump administration is that
the leak sometimes function is a better
way to actually talk to Trump so to
speak in terms of actually talking to
him if you go to Trump as Michael Wolfe
suggests if you're in Trump circle inner
circle staff whatever and you try to go
to Trump directly and say hey here's
what we should do or that's what we
should do it might work but if someone
gets to trump two minutes later and says
do this other thing then Trump's gonna
go with that other thing as we know if
you use the leaks to filter through the
media and back to Trump with the optics
that Trump often doesn't like around
media reporting it almost might be a
better way to get Trump to go along with
what it is you want him to do and that's
really a bad thing because remember
Trump doesn't really have like a
hard-and-fast personal policy philosophy
nor does he really care - he's focused
with optics he's focused on deal-making
period and other than not Obama right
we've talked about just doing anything
that Obama didn't want or reversing what
Obama did Trump will more or less go
with anything if framed correctly and
coming from the right person and what's
increasingly both sort of mind-boggling
and scary is how much influence Stephen
Miller has over Donald Trump and by
proxy how much influence Stephen Miller
has over the national course of politics
we shouldn't understate how much Trump's
desperation to just go play golf can
also be used so am
the scenario that that's going on Pat
you have people in the White House who
know one of the best ways to get action
from Trump is to leak to the media to
trigger reports that Trump won't like
and will get him to act erratically
combined with the fact that if Trump
hasn't been able to go golfing for a few
days as we saw he was forced quote
forced to stay in Washington DC because
of the shutdown this past weekend his
desperation to just do anything to get
back to golfing will go way way up yeah
and this is how the president is
deciding how much do I want to go
golfing and what messages are coming
through the media that I want to end as
a result of leaks coming out of my own
White House yeah I mean there's just so
much there and I understand you have to
try to influence your boss in some way
tour but it's troubling that these are
the people doing it I mean at least John
Kelly
he's marine he has elegant he's elegant
he has the gray hairs of experience but
right even Miller all he did was work
for Michele Bachmann he worked for Jeff
Sessions he was Steve bannon's protege
yeah guys only 32 years old and he's
essentially running the country and I'm
glad you mentioned the 32 year old thing
because that's been mentioned online and
the reaction from some has been hey
that's really ages like what's wrong if
he says things that make sense or if he
has good ideas why would you be ageist
in that way I'm not that different
I'm about as old as Stephen Miller and
although it would be lovely to be very
much involved in this way at the White
House I have enough sense of myself and
self-awareness to know that a 32 year
old it just doesn't yet have the
experience to be in the position that
Stephen Miller is in which is sort of
this de facto policy leader of the
United States he thinks he does and I'm
sure some of the people around Trump
thinks think he does I don't think John
Kelly thinks he does but that's a story
for a different day I would know that
I'm Way above above my in above my head
I guess what I'm saying I mean if you're
32 years old you can do great things you
can do great things for the country I
think hope Hicks who's one of the better
ones like 29 yeah but Stephen Miller's
title is senior policy adviser you'd
expect someone a bit older than that
when you're talking about the top
geopolitical and diplomatic decisions
that are being made in the world
by the United States you don't usually
want a 32 year old being called the
senior anything that's a red flag and
it's not being a gist and again I'm
talking about someone who is about my
age okay let's talk about that
absolutely ludicrous voter integrity
commission if you've forgotten about
this and I understand if you have I've
been trying to put it out of my head as
well because it was such a waste of time
and money
immediately after the 2016 election
Donald Trump said that three to five
million illegals voted for Hillary
Clinton and he was going to suss it all
out and figure out what happened through
something called the voter integrity
Commission Kansas lunatic Kris Kobach
was put in charge of it we heard time
and again from Sean Spicer and others
that this is really a problem even
though we knew that the real point of
this was to come up with some anecdotal
instances of double voting or dead
person of figuring somewhere as having
voted to justify further voter
suppression we knew all along that's
what it was the Trump administration
through really the voter integrity
Commission which is which is one with
the Trump administration demanded a ton
of voter data from states many states
refused to do that
and ultimately the entire thing was shut
down
DHS supposedly was going to take over
the investigation but we later learned
that actually the voter integrity
Commission destroyed all the records
they weren't going to give any of them
to the Department of Homeland Security
and nothing was being taken over
what's the news now well if we needed
any more indication that this entire
thing was a racially tinged attempt to
eventually justify suppressing the
mostly democratic non-white vote we've
now learned that in Texas the voter
integrity Commission asked for documents
on Texans with quote Hispanic last names
we'll talk in a moment about what a
Hispanic last name is but before we get
to that I'll remind you that last year
they were asking for 50 million voter
records and in Texas which has the
second largest Hispanic population in
the United States policy advisor
Williams checked the box asking for
quote Hispanic surname flag notation to
be included in the files so that they
could easily look at the so-called
Hispanic voters fortunately this was
never provided to the Trump Commission
since a lawsuit was filed blocking Texas
from sending the data to the Commission
Chris Kovac the totally horrific Kansas
Republican who ran this witch-hunt or as
they call it Commission said he didn't
know anything about this request for
Hispanic voting data saying quote at no
time did the Commission request any
state to flag surnames by ethnicity or
race well someone did and if ko Bock is
telling the truth that's actually more
disturbing because it suggests that the
Commission was so dysfunctional that
there were people requesting massive
voter rolls for Hispanic voters without
authorization from the Commission and
without anybody knowing that it was
going on independent members requesting
voter data with no oversight is
absolutely ridiculous and that proves to
me Pat that the lawsuits trying to stop
the data from being provided were
completely warranted since they were
completely out of control here yeah and
I'd imagine if three to five million
people did vote illegally and you needed
a commission like this then the
discrepancies would be everywhere you
wouldn't have to go to them you wouldn't
have to find these red flags you
wouldn't have to be court officially you
wouldn't have to pick the state with the
second biggest Hispanic population and
ask for the flagging of quote Hispanic
last names to uncover the irregularities
it would be everywhere it would be
everywhere and it would be abundantly
clear he acted on his own is what we
were being told and that's actually part
of the problem does Trump know that
there's not only a resident of Texas but
a u.s. senator from Texas with a quote
Hispanic last name who wasn't even born
in the United States his name is Ted
Cruz oh yeah his dad killed JFK right oh
yeah he's the what was that hypothesis
he was the Zodiac killer like a National
Inquirer story I think something like
that out like Cruz's father being
involved in the assassination plot of
John F Kennedy yeah but I thought there
was also more to it that Ted Cruz
self might have been the Zodiac killer I
got to be up on my Trump conspiracy
theory I know it's bones behind I can't
even remember them okay the other thing
I wanted to mention what's a Hispanic
last name I mean I'm aware of Spanish
last names and then there of course
European last names that people who have
immigrated to Latin America have like me
for example right like I am from
Argentina
I am a quote Hispanic immigrant to the
United States according to to how those
guidelines say I should be categorized
but I don't have a Hispanic last name
and then of course you've got all the
Germans and French and Italians who went
to countries like Argentina and Brazil
and Mexico and Cuba and so many others
it's a discriminatory request but it
also shows how stupid they are because
they want Hispanic Texan last names it's
all just very weird I mean maybe there
are like some indigenous surnames you
could find but yeah not the ones that
you commonly associate with Hispanic
last names like it's not Martinez or you
can guess but that's what they wanted
right that's what you imagine they want
the Serrano's and the Gonzales is
flagged in some way because they're like
these are the people that are voting for
Hillary and that we need to suss out so
then we can say look here's one dude who
voted in the wrong place or was double
registered which of course is not
illegal or something
this proves that we need even more
oppressive voter ID and voter
suppression laws and while we're at it
let's restrict early voting hours
particularly in non-white areas where
you might have black people as part of
their church-going experience deciding
to vote early or whatever the case may
be or now the good news is the data has
been destroyed supposedly and the voter
integrity commission has also been
disbanded
send me your thoughts I'm on twitter at
des Pakman the show is on twitter at
david packager the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Tracy Floyds Tracy thank you for
being a david pakman show member big
thanks to Tracy to all of the new
members that have joined us so far in
2018 and of course to the sustaining
member some of whom have been with us
now
we are going to have our first eight
year members in April in April of this
year because April of 2010 is when the
membership program started and we still
have members that joined up back in
April of 2010 I think we should have
like a birthday cake on the desk there
yes sandals absolutely and of course if
Egan's soy-free gluten free everything
free it'll be an inivisible cake there
won't be anything there it'll just be a
plate and it'll be absolutely delicious
and and everybody will be able to eat it
which is the best thing no matter what
your dietary preferences are Tracy thank
you though you can sign up and join
Tracy at david pakman.com slash
membership I crack myself up sometimes
yeah and patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and actually I would
this is a good opportunity I would say
for me to follow up about what's going
on with the critical-thinking miniseries
I've been getting a lot of emails about
this and it relates to patreon it
relates to I don't know relates to
whatever you want it to relate to we
have been developing a miniseries 12 to
15 part miniseries on critical thinking
and the way that we are sort of funding
it or subsidizing it is through our
patreon fundraiser page which you can
find at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and you will notice that we are at
2006 patrons and that all you need to do
to increase the number of patrons is by
clicking that orange become a patron
button at the top left of the page at
patreon.com a top right of the page
thank you at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and what you will notice if
you look at the bottom left of the page
is a goal of 2,100 patrons which
says when we reach 2,100 patrons we will
record edit and upload a multi-part
critical thinking miniseries first to
patrons and eventually for full
distribution this is something we've
been working on for a while now and the
intro to this miniseries is done every
clip will have a very cool animated
intro the likes of which we've never
been able to do so before to quote
George W Bush we are going to have a
very long list of topics included in
this miniseries including types of
arguments including deductive and
abductive arguments necessary and
sufficient conditions premises for an
argument including implicit premises the
difference between a valid and a sound
argument and an invalid and an unsound
argument we'll talk about logical
fallacies including ad hominem appeal to
the people the very relevant and popular
straw man fallacy which we deal with a
lot this is going to be really great and
to help get us there all you need to do
we need only ninety four more
contributors at patreon.com slash david
pakman show as of this morning we are at
2006 and we want to get to twenty one
hundred and whether you can contribute a
dollar or twenty dollars or a hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars every
contribution counts the same very
egalitarian and democratic yeah and
we're so close to that goal to I think
we should have one of those CNN style
countdown clocks oh yeah and a lot of
Records long as we know yeah sort of
like a shutdown countdown yeah we will
run the paid patron countdown that's
actually not a bad idea
and when I say whether it's 150 or $100
that it's all the same please if you can
do the hundred dollars do the hundred
dollars but what I mean is all
contributions inch us equally closer to
twenty one hundred patrons and hopefully
more information on that soon now I
think it would be best Pat if we
achieved that before February first
because what happens on the whole yeah a
month some portion of our patrons have
credit cards or debit cards on file that
have expired during the previous month
and when patreon goes to run everybody's
cards on the first we lose some patrons
I think that the it would be best if we
knock this out in January and then
that's it we're done yeah the absolute
worst case scenario would be that we get
to 2099 patron yes on January 31st and
then every source comes we get brushed
yeah they'll be bad I think if that were
the case I would just call my mom and
tell her to make a dollar contribution
yeah you know just on January 30 my mom
to get us there or at me I might call
Pat's mom yeah why not I'll call
someone's mom and ask them or a
potential future mom or even a dad why
not I mean why am I gonna discriminate
it 2018 after all it's 2018 no doubt
about it
patreon.com what are we even talking
about patreon.com slash david pakman
show okay interesting little update for
you on the Trump Russia story and of
course remember that all along we have
had a series of moving goal posts a
sliding scale of denials about how there
was no never any contact with Russians
by the Trump administration well maybe
there was contact but there was
certainly no coordination well even if
we coordinated it certainly wasn't
collusion and hey you know what even if
there was collusion collusion in and of
itself isn't illegal one of the data
points of that coordination was that
Trump Tower meeting with lawyer Russian
lawyer Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya
and we were told nothing came of it we
were told that it was a bogus meeting
that there was no follow-up and then we
realized actually there was follow-up
and then we realized actually that was
the meeting at which this quid pro quo
was intimated where if the Trump
campaign ends up receiving dirt on
Hillary from the Russians and they end
up winning they would be willing
potentially to ease Russian sanctions
that's what we call a quid pro quo and
now it turns out that not only was their
follow up and not only was there a quid
pro quo intimated to Natalia vessel it's
kaya she was in Washington DC for Donald
Trump's inauguration and attended an
inauguration party one year ago and in
fact the Washington Post has a great
piece on the many notable Russians who
were very weirdly in DC for the
inauguration so many Russians were in DC
for the inauguration in fact that the
intelligence community took notice
expressed concern the FBI was concerned
because some of the same people that
surfaced when they were investigating
possible Trump campaign connections to
Russia some of those same people were in
Washington DC for the inauguration
wealthy Russian pharmaceutical executive
Alexei repec got close enough to trump
to shake hands with him at a pre
inauguration event he was seated with
his wife right in front of the Capitol
building for the swearing-in he took a
picture with now CIA director Mike
Pompeo Viktor Vekselberg is a tycoon
who's closely aligned with the Putin
government he was in DC for the
inauguration
Boris T Tov a politician and business
advocate now running for president of
Russia with the blessing of the Kremlin
was there and Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya
the Russian lawyer from the now infamous
Trump Tower meeting was at the
inauguration and who at an inauguration
party and who invited her the one
congressman who we've heard time and
again is a Russian puppet republican
dana rohrabacher
and along with natalia vessel mats kaya
renato ahmed chin was at the same
inauguration party with natalia vessel
nats kaya they both happen to have been
at that total nothing burger trump tower
meeting the random person
Natalia vessel Nats kaya who brought
nothing to the Trump administration and
had nothing to do with anything happened
to be in Washington DC when Donald Trump
was being inaugurated just months after
she showed up at Trump Tower to give
them dirt on Hillary Clinton in exchange
for the possible easing of Russian
sanctions it's just a coincidence Pat
why is anybody worried about this stuff
well I think it makes sense that a
presidential inauguration you not only
have like congressmen and Senators there
you also have the people who helped you
win right your campaign staff and again
the audience we're gonna have Russians
in this scenario that's the most simple
explanation but it's the one that the
Trump team is going to be increasingly
apoplectic in order over in order to try
to deny so
I tried to go back and find are there
any so we've we've identified a lot of
statements that they claimed were true
which are definitely lies
maybe when Sean Spicer said at Donald
Trump's Direction that this was the
largest crowd ever for an inauguration
maybe what he should have said is this
was the largest crowd of Russians ever
to attend a president's inauguration in
Washington DC and then that statement
made hours after the inauguration would
have been true right am i digging a
little too deep here I'm a silver lion
I'm just thinking that because he said
that it was the largest attended
inauguration in presidential history I
mean that means that people were poor
again from all around the world and not
only did you have Russians you had
Ukrainians and people from Belarus and
Latvia some of whom I assume are good
people yes I really hope that Robert
Muller gets to the bottom of all of this
because there are just too many of these
so-called coincidences at this point for
them to really be coincidences we talked
about how the United States is currently
being run by children and usually it's
because of the childish way in which
they govern or the childish way in which
they think about geopolitical issues or
the way that they try to appeal to low
information trumpets it's a very long
long list of childish type behavior but
now we have something new to add to the
list the Washington Post is reporting
that Donald Trump regularly adopts one
of those stereotypical fake Indian
accents when talking about or quoting
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi this
was part of a follow-up report to the
now infamous [ __ ] country's report
where Donald Trump was referencing Haiti
and El Salvador and some African
countries we know that Trump did that we
know that Trump has referred to senator
Elizabeth Warren as Pocahontas
referencing her Native American heritage
and this is now a new type of childish
using a fake stereotypical mocking
Indian accent when talking about or
quoting the Indian Prime Minister and
I've been careful not to retroactively
Lee normalized george w bush because
george w bush was a depraved and
horrible president but from the point of
view of diplomacy and opted
George W Bush was comparatively like a
masterful diplomat compared to Donald
Trump and that's not a praise of george
w bush it's it's just making a
comparison you really don't want to know
the accents that other world leaders are
using to impersonate Trump if you think
that this is bad you should see how they
see Trump's speech in other countries
around the world I never understood
speaking about Trump here for a second
when people speak one language and they
sort of make fun of how people speak
English as a second language or as a
third language I don't find it at all
offensive to joke about accents right
it's a really minor thing it's often in
good fun when it comes to drugs Trump
it's just part of his childish nature
but when you only speak one language and
there's people who can speak two
languages or three and communicate
effectively but with an accent in those
other languages look what is there to
make fun of but just it's it's it's
quite impressive actually when people
have multiple languages that they can
communicate it there's no reason to make
fun of them because they still made an
effort to learn your language and can
still communicate with you I actually
find that when people think to make fun
of how someone speaks a language that's
their second language the person doing
the poking fun probably only speaks one
language because when you when you speak
multiple languages you understand how
difficult it is to make yourself
understood sort of in a fluid way in
another language I learned English as a
Second Language I learned it very young
but my native language is Spanish and
I'm around people who speak with accents
all the time it just doesn't strike me
as funny like I wouldn't even occur to
me to mock them because yet people learn
languages at different ages and you
don't always sound like a native speaker
and I understand you know it can be done
in a comedic setting and it can be done
in jest but it's certainly not
professional no and it's certainly not
presidential and it comes across as
offensive in some settings - is it extra
funny that Trump's English is terrible
and that's the only language he speaks
he speaks at the lowest grade level of
any president in the modern era of
evaluating the level at which presidents
speak
and he's making fun of how other people
speak English there's something weird
about looking my English complex I would
say like one of those complexes yeah it
must have some name I don't know what it
would be but I'm sure we can assign
assign a name to it
remind me Pat at some point to tell this
reminds me I don't have time to tell it
now but the how do you say cheese in
English story I don't think I've ever
told the story maybe on the bonus show
could join us on our subreddit where you
can discuss this or any other stories
from today's show david pakman.com slash
rubp i'ts the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'd like to welcome to the program today
Stephen Payson who received his
doctorate in economics from Columbia
University in 1991 he's been a
professional economist and adjunct
professor for about 32 years his latest
book which we'll be talking about today
is how economics professors can stop
failing us the discipline at a
crossroads this is a very very
interesting topic to me Stephen as
someone who studied economics at both
the undergraduate and graduate level
regularly interviews economists
regularly debates economics with both
economists and non economists what would
you assess as the real crisis of
economic professorship that's going on
right now
sure okay well I think first of all
before I you know say what the crisis is
I just want to say that there's a lot of
professors who are doing very good work
so I don't want it to seem like you know
I'm condemning all professors anything
like that certainly but you know so
having said that I think there is a
crisis it's pretty much a crisis where
the profession is too much interested
and too engaged and in a way too trapped
by its own games that it plays
internally for its career promotion and
its publications and the kind of work
that a lot of academic economists do is
really serving a sort of game that
doesn't produce much for society give us
an example of that in other words what's
something that economist economics
professors might put time into that you
believe doesn't serve society is it the
publishing of theoretical economics
articles or what is it right I think a
lot of it is
a focus too much on theory and too much
impressing people you know other
economists theoretical economists in the
same club so for example I had studied
for a couple decades technological
change and trying to predict patterns of
technological change and it was a very
interdisciplinary approach which you
know others some other economists also
take but the in my view the literature
on the effects of technological change
have been dominated much more by theory
where the theory just builds up on on
highly mathematical constructs based on
very very strong assumptions and it
kinds it kind of it kind of produces
more and more publications without you
know shedding light on what's truly
going on in technological change so let
me tell you what one of the concerns I
have with the field of economics at
least in most of American colleges and
universities and you tell me number one
if you agree or disagree that this is an
issue and ideally whether you think it's
connected to what you just outlined
which is I am very concerned about the
percentage of the time that is spent
teaching sort of rational actor
traditional economics relative to the
amount of time that's spent really
exploring the last 20 years of
behavioral economics and sort of the way
that a lot of these concepts actually
manifest in the real world do you agree
that that's a problem and is that
related to the problem you've identified
yes it is I agree it's a problem and I
and I agree that it's related I think
what's happened in economics and part of
it might be tribute abode to work by
Gary Becker and others has been this
kind of option that we don't have to
truly understand human behavior if we
have an interesting model that we can
study and we can study the math of
properties of that model and impress
each other with what we've discovered in
our mathematical models so it's sort of
like understanding human behavior is an
option and there's a substitute for it
which is you know more high-powered
theory where we just you know rediscover
essentially our assumptions about it and
it's amazing how this has affected so
many things because it also affects
economic policy because then you know if
you if you have an an economic problem
and we're trying to solve it and a
distinguished professor has a certain
theory based primarily on assumptions
but then can say I published a proof
that this is the best solution it's real
with the profession it doesn't have a
capability to really challenge that so
there isn't a strong enough leadership
to say wait a minute how much of these
assumptions are grounded in reality you
know the assumptions are published in
them in an impressive journal then that
sort of like automatically elevates it
to acceptance do you believe that sort
of classical rational actor economics is
still a good basis for s students of
economics to first sort of understand if
humans were totally rational if we had
completely free markets if the laws of
supply and demand applied 100 percent in
the real world here's sort of how it
would work and then later be introduced
to for example the teachings of
behavioral economics or the limits of
capitalism or whatever else is that's
still the right order in your mind or
would you teach economics in a different
order I think it the the simple basis of
the sort of neoclassical framework could
still be taught at the very first level
of explaining what supply and demand is
and maximizing utility and what
determines prices and everything else so
I think there's still that basic you
know element but then
you know rather than but then soon
thereafter we've got to introduce all
the caveats and all the other things
that determine human behavior before
going you know before piling it higher
and deeper into our own reality I think
so maybe I don't I don't know if you can
speak to this but I think that so my
undergraduate economics degree is from
the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst Massachusetts and I believe that
that was a unique Department insofar as
you know I had Marxist economist Richard
Wolff teaching my introduction to
macroeconomics a hundred level class as
a first year student and then very
quickly I was able to move into you know
the late Steve Resnick's class on
Marxian economics and other classes that
explored sort of the limits of
neoclassical economics was that
relatively unusual as far as economics
departments go I think so I think that
is very unusual you know I'm aware of
certain that you know departments like
that and some still exist you know but
that is unusual but we have to we have
to also be cautious because I think when
we're talking about I guess what we're
saying here is you're talking about
pluralism and economics and different
you know views other than the sort of
the neoclassical framework one thing
that that I talk about my book is we can
get too caught up in those scholarly
discussions and like you could say well
well this kind of helps round out
economics so that we understand things
better that's true but then you could
also you know we create a lot of other
distortions because people can have
scholars in the room talking about you
know what did Marx mean when he said
this that and the other thing and
and that that wouldn't be very
productive for economics today either so
just the general you know challenging
the simplicity of the new classical
framework is very good and principles
basic principles like labor exploitation
and those kind of things are good too
but if we get too much into the weeds
and to scholarly discussions then a lot
of professors in those subfields tend to
have the same problem trying to impress
each other not necessarily with
mathematics but with you know their
quotations of what scholars had written
hundreds of years ago that kind of thing
do you think that so again anecdotally
when I was at the University of
Massachusetts economics was not part of
the business school it was it was part
of social sciences or humanities call it
what you want it has since been moved
into the business school and this is
something that we're actually seeing
around the country that include
increasingly economics is being put
under the umbrella of learning about
business is that something that makes
sense or should we be concerned about
that I I would be concerned about that
you know you have to take these things
into context so if they're if it's a
small university they simply may not
have an economics department right and
they may teach a few economics classes
and it would go into the business school
but like when I study economics at
Columbia was in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences was separate from the
business school and I think that's right
because they think economics you know
really should be seen as as a science as
a social science with applications to
business without also applications to
public policy applications international
trade you know that kind of thing
how concerned are you about sort of pop
economics I guess for lack of a better
term that's leading to just a lot of
people believing that they understand
economics in a way that they can
accurately assess what sort of public
and government policies would be
beneficial to the economy is that having
a real impact on government or is that
something that's just sort of going on
in media and is not impacting public
policy
um I think it's always impacted public
policy and it's gotten worse in some
ways because what's happened and maybe
there might be some trends you know to
improve things recently but it's hard to
say but what's what's happened is that
models have become so complicated and so
dependent on very specific assumptions
that you can approach them with with
alternative sets of assumptions that
essentially rediscover those assumptions
and make very different conclusions so
you know if you wanna you know if you
want a model that says that if we reduce
the tax rate the economy will grow you
can produce a model like that if you
want a model that says the opposite you
could produce them on like that and and
you know the the devil is in the details
of the assumptions and the math and and
that kind of thing and even the way data
are processed them and measured and
interpreted so what that what that has
meant for public policy is that there's
a lot of distrust and perhaps rightfully
so in the applications of economic
models in general and so that really
limits our ability to use economics
because if we don't trust economics then
we're just basing policies on gut
instinct or what we really want to
believe if we don't like taxes we'll
think it taxes are bad if we want public
programs you think taxes is good to
finance or close programs and so it's
kind of like economics has become so
theoretical that it's it's created a
disbelief in economics and so a lot of
public leaders simply don't believe
economics we've been speaking on even
pacing the book is how economics
professors can stop failing us the
discipline at a crossroads very
interesting topic and I find it
particularly important right now Steven
thanks so much for talking to us about
this can I just I just want to show this
because the book is on sale half-price
oh sure ah and it's a coupon at this
website absolutely fantastic ere leap
org
he got PDF for a radio and podcast
audience Stephen thank you so much well
thank you thank you very much the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I've been talking about this for years
and it's getting closer and closer it's
what I call deathless meat or some like
to call it lab-grown meat there's a
company called Memphis meats among
others actually and they are about ready
to offer lab-grown meat to the masses as
soon as 2021 which is just under three
years from now a Bill Gates and Richard
Branson are some of the investors in
this company and they say that they have
already produced beef chicken and duck
directly from animal cells without
needing to raise and slaughter actual
animals and the way that it works is by
combining cells in tanks and bio
reacting it with other elements and
nutrients Memphis meats is doing this
there's also a company called beyond
meat there's another one called
impossible foods that's working on the
same thing and this would address a lot
of the concerns that people have who
either don't eat meat or want to reduce
meat consumption if you don't like the
killing of animals it solves that if you
don't like the environmental impact of
raising animals and the water and food
consumption it solves that if you don't
like the possible or known health
concerns around eating too much meat it
actually addresses that because you can
create this meat without animals that
are eating antibiotics and possibly
breathing or eating contaminated air or
grass or grains or whatever so I guess
that would probably make it healthier as
well
the main issue has actually been price
which is coming down drastically the
first time I reported on this I think
one burger had a cost of like three
hundred thousand dollars I reported on
it again three years ago the price was
down to the cost was down to ten to
twelve dollars that doesn't include you
know markup and shipping and warehousing
and everything else but that that was
the reduction that we saw would vegan
Pat eat lab-grown deathless meat yeah I
think I would I mean I would at least
try it now my taste buds have
recalibrated for at this point and I
don't really crave meat so much your soy
boy now as oh yeah as the hay tree it's
like this I'm such a soy boy at this
point but what I do think is
those who eat a standard American diet
yeah it would be a good way for them to
transition and serve like more of a
vegan vegetarian approval no doubt about
it and I've said before I believe that
the consumption of meat from raised and
slaughtered animals is going to become
more and more niche over time it's very
hard to imagine in 50 years still
raising and slaughtering animals for me
oh the way we do now I mean it seems
totally unlikely its unsustainable to
the land the water we don't have the
resources I'm not sure about eliminated
like it might become a very luxury good
we're like in 50 years if you have
actual real animals that have been
slaughtered for meat it would be sort of
a novelty in some way I don't know if
it'll go away but it's going to be
reduced drastically and this I think is
probably a pretty good path forward in
hunting will still be around I mean if
you live off the grid you don't no
choice but to go kill your food yeah but
most of us live within the general
vicinity of a grocery store and have no
need for eating meat at this point an
interesting question I saw online was
could the process by which this meat is
created in a lab be miniaturized so that
in the future you could have a home
machine and you create your meat
on-demand right before you cook it or
something like that
yeah I don't like like making her own
beer sure or you know growing your own
vegetables in the backyard that kind of
thing same type of thing yeah now out of
curiosity would it be okay or ethical or
moral or taboo to grow meat for animals
you wouldn't normally eat like for
example a lot of people don't eat whale
whales are smart social whatever right a
lot of people say I don't eat whale even
though some countries eat whale I would
never eat whale would that apply to
lab-grown whale or would that eliminate
all of those problem I don't know
because I think people draw the line at
a very weird spot like most people say
that it's okay to eat cows and chickens
and pigs but it's not okay to eat dogs
and cats know that you don't well it
depends on what country right and so
yeah it's different but yeah it depends
on the culture but I just say we
shouldn't kill and eat animals
altogether so I don't have that same
moral dilemma about eating a whale you
know I'm increasingly thinking that
there is going to be we're getting off
top
but a crisis in the vegan community over
the fact that we are learning more and
more about plants that panic in a way
that is reminiscent of sentience and
bivalves that seem to have less quote
sentience than some plants I think that
is definitely going to be now that I'm
worried about it but an upcoming crisis
well vegan community first I would want
to see that these plants feel pain and
also if you want to eliminate or reduce
plant suffering right you still want to
go for that vegan or vegetarian approach
because then you don't have to filter
all those plants through animals because
the animals are eating the plants first
and then people eat the animals the
animals are eating the plants and then
people like to get a cow or a chicken or
a pig to its size it's got to eat soy
and it's gonna eat alfalfa and all these
different plants right to get it to the
size that it is yeah great that 2,000
pound animal right and so but but okay
well they're all up on this on the
plants would be eaten yes in the
environmental impact aspect of it send
me your thoughts on this would you eat
lab-grown I don't know me chimpanzee or
something like that what would be the
ethics of that
a new poll claims that 0% of Iceland
errs under age 25 believe in the Bible
creation story and I have many questions
about the number zero percent because
the poll was taken number one by an
Icelandic polling company for the
Icelandic ethical humanist association
and they've released zero information
about the methodology my instinct of
that is that if the number truly is zero
percent it's because a very small number
of people were polled but let's not
focus on zero percent specifically let's
just assume it's a very low number of
Icelanders under 25 who believe in the
Bible creation story we've also found
that there is a major urban rural split
in Iceland on religious belief which is
increasingly something we're noticing
around the world if you are rural you
are way more likely to believe the Bible
creation story than if you are urban
which basically in Iceland means you
live in Reykjavik because that's not
that's as far as I know the only real
city of any size a small country I think
the entire population of the countries
like three or four hundred thousand
total so in any case big urban rural
but what's clear is Iceland is very
secular and other than the problems of
trying to avoid inbreeding because the
population is so small and the
anti-semitism which has been a problem
for many years for Iceland they seem to
be doing fine with a smaller and smaller
amount of religion the biggest the
fastest growing religion in Iceland is
called zu ISM zu is M naught zo low and
in it's an ancient Sumerian religion and
kind of considered more or less a
protest group so I questioned the exact
numbers of this poll but what what's
very clear is that in the developed
world people are moving away from
religion more and more quickly and that
is going to be very interesting over the
next ten fifteen twenty five and even
fifty years because I don't see anything
reversing this trend and we're going to
be in an increasingly religion less
world over time it's an interesting poll
too because I wonder about what if you
talk about like the Bible creation story
yeah if it has to be literally
interpreted or can it just be
figuratively interpreted like when it
says that God created the world in seven
days you have to be seven 24-hour days
periods I think it actually uh yeah
you're saying I don't think that one
matters because my sense is if you don't
believe God created the world in seven
days you probably don't believe that
even if each day is a thousand years
that God created the world in seven
thousand years you probably either
believe it or don't
I would guess but yeah there's probably
some people who are in-between who
depending on how they're interpreting
the question might answer differently I
think there's something to that but big
picture you also don't literally
interpret these poll results as no one
under 25 believes Bible creation no it
just seems like they didn't find anyone
yeah in the particular poll they just
didn't find anybody very interesting
I've only been to the Iceland Airport
I've never spent time there but I would
like to go there I think it would be a
super interesting place to go we've got
a voicemail from the Eggman about
knishes interestingly enough a prime
topic for the Eggman let's take a listen
to what he had to say Dave when you get
a finish at that cool bakery in Boston
these are round baked ones or the square
fried knishes
right I'm really tired of the round
baked ones I can't even get a square
pride condition in western New York
anymore the kind that the Muslims sell
of the street carts in New York City how
come if you buy a knish a kosher potato
food in New York City it's usually a
Muslim guy selling it you from a street
cart serious question which line you
prefer not the question about the Muslim
selling the sort of course Shalom
brother
yeah shell on bag man um at Michael's
deli it's not a bakery but it's deli
they have the square knish it's not
fried as far as I know it is baked and
then you flattop it if you order it
there of course then you can take it to
go and then toss it back into the oven I
don't recommend using the microwave
because it will sort of soften it up
yeah I prefer an oven or if you can
flattop it that's really the way to go
but yes they are the square knishes at
Michael's deli
although mammal is delicatessen in
Cambridge Massachusetts does have the
round knishes which I know
Pat's very concerned about finding a
round knish in the Boston area and you
can do it you can do it so you know I
don't think I've had a condition before
thus I don't have a knish preference but
and on that note of D rip total
derailment is the story we will wrap up
the show and speak
you want her
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you